Schoolhouse Rock told me three is a
magic number we'll see inferred so
inferno is the third book to movie
adaptation of the Dan Brown series
directed by Ron Howard starring Tom
Hanks first one DaVinci Code second one
Angels & Demons now the third one
Inferno and in infernal Robert Langdon
has to follow a set of clues to find the
answers revolving around a plague that's
going to be unleashed on mankind wiping
95% of us out the clues of course are
revolving and centered around Dante's
Inferno sounds cool right actually it
does sound really cool about a plug
being unleashed revolving around clues
from Dante's Inferno is actually quite a
boring movie really Tom Hanks character
Robert Langdon the reason he's able to
carry a movie or a franchise is his
brain he's just smart and I like smart
people I like it when people can put
together puzzles like it's the reason I
watched house for every season it was on
TV that in house is sarcastic castle I
like that too and in this movie even
that is compromised because the movie
starts out Langdon is in a bed tripping
balls on fever dreams hallucinating he
has amnesia he's not at his full a game
and that condition is with him through a
lot of the movie it raised me that one
season 224 I forgot what season it was
but Jack Bauer comes back from China and
he's totally broken he's not good at his
job anymore and he can't beat
information out of guys I remember
thinking it's like Jack Bauer's not
really Jack Bauer that's really
compromising this season as a whole one
of the reasons anyone like Robert
Langdon is not really Robert Langdon and
it's compromising the movie as old as
much as that is a Fault in the movies
not the only fault of the movie really
narrative Lee speaking the first half of
the movies just kind of jumbled up and
it's just throwing [ __ ] out you're like
I don't even why hmm
are we putting stuff together now not
only is it boring but it's choppy with
all these favorite dreams and visions
that he's having you don't really make
sense of it because you have no baseline
for any of it granted the movie's
supposed to make you feel confused
because you're supposed to be as
confused as he is but the movies not
clear to when he gets better and he
starts piece and [ __ ] together so it's
not like you're with him it's not like
you're like he's confused you're
confused he's better you're better
you're solving [ __ ] with the movie no
it's like he's confused you're confused
he starts solving [ __ ] you're like oh I
guess Louie's like angels and demons
Meets The Hangover really but at least
the hangover
started out you see where everyone's
coming from then there's a big gap in
their memory and they need to start
solving [ __ ] that would have worked
better for this movie show Langdon doing
stuff and then show this big Gaby like
wakes up three days later is like I
don't know what happened I have to
backtrack I've traced things have to
find out why I ended up there and why
this [ __ ] happened leading up to it
there's no baseline there's no 15-minute
setup of his character really anyone
else the movie starts out for less than
a hospital bed he's like I'm missing
time and you're like I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't care what you're missing because
I don't feel like we're missing anything
because it wasn't there for any of it so
doesn't mean anything to me maybe it was
that way in the book fine but it's all
about how you translate book to movie
adaptation and translation it's a skill
not gonna lie it is sometimes people
don't do a well or maybe it is maybe the
book is just like the movie and the book
is boring too I haven't read it I don't
know however in watching this I was
thinking to myself this would be a more
interesting book to read then movie to
watch the supporting cast is good in it
Felicity Jones was fine she actually
there are a couple of lines in the road
one trailer that made me go from I hope
you're good in this movie then in here
she commits you're like oh I am looking
forward to you in that rug one movie a
dude's just the best part of the movie
the best part of the movie but really
Inferno took everything that made the da
Vinci Code and even angels and demons
work which is ultimately control of
information and that's interesting and
turn it into a kind of a cliche we gotta
find the bad thing before the bad guy
does the bad thing how many times have
you seen that well here's one more for
you the movies choppy it's slow it's
boring admittedly the last part of the
last act was actually pretty intense
maybe it's only intense because
comparatively the two hours leading up
to that you're just kind of indifferent
about all I know is the last part of the
last act I enjoy it's not that the
movies terrible is that it's just blah
and you're not gonna remember inferno in
t-minus one day ya already forgot the
scenery was great I feel like every
review you're going to see is going to
be like you know the scenery in this
movie is beautiful because it is because
Europe has some great luscious
wonderfully beautiful cities and when
you can put them on film that's great
but it doesn't make the film itself
great alright guys so inferno have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]